Aras as we can see simply believe that
the relationship between the persons of
the Trinity had a different relationship
than the nyine group did although aside
from this issue we can of course find
other ways in which he diverges from
would be Orthodoxy too above all Aries
wanted to safeguard God's uniqueness and
timelessness if the son is of the same
essence or substance as the father as
the nine creed holds that seems to
compromise this nature of God because a
son comes from a father he's begotten
from the father th there is change in
the godhead so what then is the point of
the begetting and the father son
relationship that's mentioned in the
bible if that relationship doesn't mean
what it does